há nove anos atrás eu meu marido
planejava engravidar
foram quatro anos tentando muitos exames
a descoberta de uma endometriose que
incluiu a retirada de uma das minhas
trompas por que ele é tão planejado
sonho parecia cada vez mais distante
até que um dia quando estava prestes a
fazer um tratamento descobrir que estava
grávida
joana foi concebida naturalmente parecia
um milagre
a gravidez foi ótima super saudável mas
quando estava entre o sexto eo sétimo
mês
um dos exames apontou uma má formação
cardíaca
ela tinha chamado deve haver completo é
uma afirmação grave que inclui uma
abertura entre os átrios uma abertura
entre veículos e uma válvula única
aquele tão planejado parto natural teve
que dar lugar a uma cesárea
a evitar maiores riscos que correu tudo
bem joana nasceu saudável e veio para o
meu colo
o seu rostinho sereno e rosado minutos
depois no entanto pediatra e meu marido
joão entraram na sala de parto com
diagnóstico de síndrome de down
naquele momento as dúvidas uma mãe de
primeira viagem foram potencializados
exponencialmente
como seria ser uma mãe como seria sua
mãe de alguém especial
que desafios eu teria que enfrentar
dificuldades eu teria pela frente
meu cérebro não falar agora vou fazer
perguntas eu não tinha nenhuma das
respostas
sorte minha que minutos depois da fala
do pediatra maria da verdade pra mim
disse ela é bebê mais lindo do mundo
naquele momento a minha certeza foi um
pouco amenizada
seja lá o que me esperava eu sabia que
não estava só as dúvidas sobre a
síndrome de down não durarão alguns
minutos entre a minha transferência da
sala de parto pro quarto porque logo
depois meu cérebro foi invadido com mais
uma surpresa mas que a joana teria que
ficar na uti e se alimentar através de
uma sonda por incapacidade de sugar o
esforço da amamentação e levava seus
batimentos cardíacos e por vezes ela
desmaiada me doía não tem aquele contato
físico tão cheio de significado que era
a mãe
a ação mas tive que lidar com essa
frustração depois de alguns dias na uti
e com a ajuda de alguns medicamentos
finalmente tivemos alta pra casa pra
joana conheceu martin
no entanto depois dia ela foi perdendo a
sua capacidade de sugar e com 20 dias de
vida a gente teve que retornar ao
hospital
a partir daí foi então quase quatro
meses de muitas surpresas e muitas
decisões difíceis
a primeira cirurgia paliativa para a
inserção de uma sonda ligada diretamente
ao estômago para que a joana pudesse
reduzir o esforço da amamentação e
ganhar tempo e peso até a cirurgia
cardíaca cirurgia paliativa feita com
sucesso
correu bem mas no pós operatório
joana não conseguia sair do respirador o
fluxo de sangue que o coração jogava por
hora de três vezes o normal
o pulmão é uma esponja ele encharcava e
ela parava de respirar depois da
terceira tentativa a roleta russa
cirurgia cardíaca de altíssima gravidade
e complexidade na zona abaixo do peso da
idade recomendada
já joana venceu todas as estatísticas
como engenheiro que eu sou aprendi que
neste mundo cada vez mais incerto
probabilidade de 0.1 às vezes pode dar
durante esse período o hospital refletir
muito sobre essa imprevisibilidade da
vida e de como a gente precisa evitar
que os pensamentos errados nos domine e
nos impeçam nos paralisa nos impeçam de
mover a ação
já pararam para pensar quando algo sai
diferente do que a gente planejou
muitas vezes a gente fica frustrado com
raiva tenta achar um culpado muitas
vezes até sem culpa
quanta energia a gente gasta uns porquês
quando na verdade deveria estar focando
nos o case uso keys tira o nosso
pensamento do passado voltam ele
presente nos colocam novamente em
movimento naquele momento também uma
frase
ela é uma dita pela cardiologista não me
sai da cabeça e virou meu mantra até
hoje vivo um dia de cada vez
quando o problema é muito complexo se a
gente quebra ele em partes e tenta
solucionar uma partida de cada vez
a chance de você resolver muito maior e
você controla sociedade naquele momento
antes da cirurgia
não adiantava ficar pensando como seria
a vida da joana
depois ela teria uma vida normal como é
que é seu pós operatório e sequer estava
conseguindo um ato mais simples da vida
que era respirar
eu aprendi também nem se inscreveu em
etapas que a gente precisa comemorar
cada pequena vitória e comemorei
eu comemorei a virada do ano
mesmo estando na uti e comemorou o
primeiro aniversário de meses dela com
um bolo no hospital mesmo ela está
entubada
algumas pessoas não sabíamos que éramos
loucos
joão comemorando uma vida e nossa filha
banda
outras vieram pra gente agradecer e
dizer que linda aquela celebração de
vida em um ambiente que se fala tanto de
doença e morte
sem querer a gente estava dando
esperança aos pacientes daquele andar
por aí fomos celebrando cada pequena
vitória como quando ela o seu
coraçãozinho bateu próximo a 100 pela
primeira vez eu não resisti tirei foto
do monitor ou quando pude pegar no colo
depois de tanto tempo internada na volta
pra casa ainda foi difícil alimentação
ainda havia gás terá restrição de
visitas eram 16 remédios atribuído entre
28 dólares por dia
sei que vencer o cansaço para não errar
garante que tudo desse certo
um dos remédios que tomava
quero viajar o viagra além da do efeito
popularmente conhecido
para quem não sabe ele é um remédio
z é hipertensão arterial pulmonar
a caixinha só vem 4 ea joão tomava meio
por dia
então eu tinha que me tocar eu morava em
copacabana vocês podem imaginar ainda na
farmácia cheio de idosos à minha volta
eu gritava me ver cinco caixas de viagra
jornaleiro que me acompanhou e sabia de
tudo e costumava espalhar brincar que eu
havia voltado à maternidade a todo vapor
segundo o psiquiatra austríaco victor
franklin o humor é uma arma poderosa na
luta pela sobrevivência em um dos seus
livros em que ele relata o período em
que esteve no campo de concentração
sobre aqueles que ele observou que
confortável uns aos outros com palavras
com humor e muitas vezes com seu último
pedaço de pão
ele dizia eles podem ter sido poucos mas
são prova suficiente de tudo pode ser
retirado do homem - a última de suas
liberdades a escolher a atitude perante
qualquer circunstância
bom hoje ao longo de 65 anos
ela demorou um pouquinho para andar tem
ainda limitações na fala é acompanhada
de terapeutas e médicos mas está na
escola uma criança feliz
como vocês podem ver outro dia estava
triste com o que tinha acontecido no
trabalho ela percebeu e veio até mim
disse mamãe não fica triste não
a vida é bela ela tirou aquilo eu me
lembrei que havia uma canção do patati
patatá que ela gostava de escutar e ela
só se houve alguma maneira com a
percepção do sentimento que eu estava
naquele momento
quanto à sensibilidade após o nascimento
da zona passei a ver o mundo sobre outra
lente eu passei a admirá lo pela sua
força sua vontade e sua luta não só pela
sobrevivência mas por conseguir coisas
que pra gente vem tão fácil muitas vezes
automática
o paciente chegar na minha filha não que
falta mas o que ela tem abundância e que
muitas vezes falta em nós
e ajuda continua me surpreendendo todo
dia
semana passada mesmo fui a trabalho para
os estados unidos
e elas não me acompanharam estava
curiosa para saber como seria ela no
país que fala outra língua como
cognitivo ela funcionaria na minha
surpresa do som mis a emigração amy
solta um golo monumental aí eu não era
surpresa pensei será que alguém de
inglês da escola já está dando esse
resultado não será mais uma referência
dos desenhos que ela assistir no youtube
no dia seguinte a gente numa lanchonete
e uma senhora fez um elogio pra ela
estava ensinando pra ela como agradecer
e dizer tem que ela não só conseguiu
dizer como engatou tem que ir longe
a senhora se derreteu e eu joão na hora
pensamos essa nossa filha realmente uma
peça rara joana nesses cinco anos
já nos ensinou tanta coisa nos ensinou
que a vida é imprevisível que nem tudo
sai como a gente planejou
acho que a gente consegue se adaptar
ensinou que precisa viver um dia de cada
vez e celebrar cada pequeno de tora
muitas vezes podem ser grandes momentos
me ensinou o amor dá sentido à nossa
própria existência que é possível ser
feliz mesmo nos momentos difíceis
ensinou que o humor amenizador e que a
nossa atitude pode mudar significa mente
significativamente um rumo de qualquer
situação a fechar
falei pra vocês um trecho da carta que
escrevi para ela na véspera da cirurgia
cantiga
depois de muitos dias o hospital chegou
a hora da cirurgia grande no peito medo
dor de cabeça mas hoje quando eu disser
sim sereno e feliz tive a certeza de que
tudo vai dar certo de que você decidiu
ficar e que vai lutar até o fim
não para estar connosco e construir a
família que tanto desejamos não importa
seu coração ver um perfeito
se você tem síndrome de down pois pra
mim pro seu pai dessa criança mais
perfeita do universo
não mudaremos nada em você e te amo como
você é e principalmente por você ser
assim você é uma guerreira e nos enche
de orgulho
desejei muito filha quero que você saiba
disso
você me faz feliz e prometo que teremos
muitos momentos gostosos para curtir
juntas chama minha filha minha princesa
minha guerreira nada toda certo que o
amor triunfos sobre todas as coisas
também brigando